Rich Eisen of the NFL Network and the
Rich Eisen show on DirecTV all right
rich let's start with the poll question
I would go with Randi Ross's career the
hall-of-famer every single time mmm the
reason why I guess is uh you know I mean
shoot the NFL network's been on since oh
three week ten and the only event I've
seen more than Super Bowls is Hall of
Fame inductions because we went to the
the one the summer of Oh three just to
take the tires on things and introduce
ourselves before you launched and so
I've seen that and I've been you know
honored humbled however you want to say
it too host jacket dinners the dinner
where they get the jacket slipped on and
and and and one time when Berman
introduced Ralph Wilson I I did the
entire ceremony the whole shootin match
there's nothing like that club there is
nothing that comes close to that Club
there are hundreds upon thousands of men
who have been fortunate enough to win
Super Bowls and their careers multiple
but that's a very exclusive club and you
want to be part of that one here it's
just amazing watching these guys walk
around talk to each other you know rib
each other for some who haven't won
Super Bowls in that room Dan Fouts who
never won one never never even got to
one I saw him smoking cigars outside a
hotel veranda once with a Mean Joe green
sitting there and and Deacon Jones
sitting there and John Madden strolling
up I mean it's that's the goat pasture
you want to be part of Super Bowls aside
that's that's the ultimate would you
rather have the career of Ray Lewis or
Randy Moss oh I mean I take the Super
Bowl yeah of course Louis yeah oh
absolutely you want the Super Bowl ring
- I mean you want the furry
it's the ultimate rarefied air are the
first ballot Hall of Famers with Super
Bowl rings
I mean that is the most I don't know the
number off the top of my head but you
know that's the difference between you
know I guess what Marshall Faulk and
LaDainian Tomlinson I guess you know
first ballot guys but one's got a ring
you know one dozen and by the way you
know we should we should CMOS and tio in
the same class it's time for tio to go
in hmm last year we saw two guys one who
waited awhile and Terrell Davis and one
being a first-ballot hall-of-famer from
the same running back group with LT and
Terrell Davis we should see Mawson and
tio this year best game tomorrow is what
Lions Vikings that's a thousand percent
that's huge Vikings could essentially
wrap up that division with with five
games to go obviously anything can
happen but that's it they would sweep
the Lions which which is easily the team
that that that can catch them that
they're the best team other than the
Vikings in that division the other ones
have no chance to win the division so
the Vikings can essentially wrap it up
sweep the season series from the Lions
and end it so that's there's the most on
the line there's some intrigue obviously
with the Cowboys season on the line at
five and five and here come the Chargers
you know the Chargers their annual
slogan could be you know we should be
and you fill in the blank and if you
fill in the blank with the exact reverse
of their record and this year instead of
it being six before they could easily be
seven and three eight and two and they
out of the four and six mosh pit that's
in the AFC I think they've got the best
chance to to get in the playoffs based
on what they have so that's an
interesting one too and then you know
Giants Redskins is always fascinating
certainly with Washington at four and
six and on the bracket Cowboys I was
looking at the schedule though rich and
and they're underdogs in this game
against the Chargers for entertainment
purposes only but I'm thinking that they
could probably they can win four or five
but can nine wins get you into the
postseason know nine wins not getting in
the NFC and the Cowboys are not win it
the Cowboys are not winning out they're
not winning
they're not even gonna win I did there
they're in deep trouble Dan I mean they
I know they're getting there left tackle
back and maybe Shawn Lee returns too but
those eight yard gains for for for
Alfred Mars those are the 20 30 yard
gains that that Zeke would come up with
and you know they're other than other
than Dez who wins a one-on-one battle
outside or inside I mean they have a big
problem major problem and you know I
could even see them finishing honestly 6
and 10 7 & 9
Zeke comes back they do take on Seattle
which obviously is losing a war of
attrition and their defense but you know
and that's going to Philadelphia week 17
I mean even if Philly has nothing to
play for they're gonna play for knocking
the Cowboys out that's for damn sure if
they kiss always would go 6 and 10 Jason
Garrett job on the line that's a good
question I don't know it really depends
on on Jerry Jones's appetite for change
I mean I do remember this is a thirst
this is a Saturday night version of
Thursday Night Football and when we used
to call it that years ago this was o 9
the Saints were undefeated if you
remember they were 13 and oh and the
Cowboys went into the the Superdome and
Wade Phillips as a coach and Jerry Jones
came to our said I think I told the
story on show just a few weeks ago right
not that night he just didn't he did not
want to lose that game cuz he did not
want to make a change in coach and they
want it and he eventually had to make
the change in the middle of season the
next year I don't know I I don't think
so so my apologies to Shea out there
listening
I think the gingers gonna stay because
look Jerry could basically say it was
all set up and then where he could even
say it was a setup however he chooses to
view it with with Zeke but they won
three in a row look terrific that kid is
really special and when you lose your
left tackle and your middle of your
defense at the same time it's tough to
overcome these Rich Eisen from the NFL
Network also DirecTV the Rich Eisen show
the
follows this one why hasn't Jimmy
Garoppolo played I I don't know other
than the fact that they had that by week
sitting there at week 11 it's not as if
they had to rush him out there to make a
playoff run that they want to give him
the opportunity to get in the playbook
and learn the terminology and be
successful he should play this weekend I
mean it would make no sense to me well
you want to see what CJ Beathard as I
mean they should they should plan these
last six games and start them right now
certainly against the Seattle defense
again that is without its best players
in the back end and Atlanta just ripped
him up and let's see what you have in
him I would be surprised if he doesn't
play this weekend I really would it's
it's it's time you you spent the money
in the treasure and and and it's time to
put them out there see what you have
feels like it's organizational tanking
well say Quan for say Quan I mean like
Noah ruins particular you try are you
targeting well you don't have to you
already have your quarterback so now you
try all that yeah I trade out of that
but if I if I would know oh I would take
say Quan Barclay oh my gosh him in that
I mean in all honesty when I see say
Quan Berkeley and I see him play he
looks just like Devonta Freeman to me he
really does he's got the same style he's
got this and he he might even be more
talented and putting him in that offense
come on Shannon getting him there your
gun should meet G oh yeah man he's
mister real you don't have you obviously
didn't play this year oh my god where'd
he go though what happened he won the
Heisman in September he did I mean he
ran into some really good Big Ten
competition I mean I mean come on you're
gonna have big-time competition next
year in the NFL no I know that but I
mean at the running back position it's
it ain't easy and by the way while I'm
the subject Baker Mayfield should win
the Heisman um you know and what
happened is
last week I think there's something that
he'll have to learn from and he'll
answer questions at the combine about
you know if Kansas can trigger you what
about the Seattle Seahawks you know yeah
and so he's gonna have to answer that
but I I would I wouldn't discount him at
all because of what we saw this weekend
who's coming up on the show Bob Saget
stopping by
you're gonna go we're gonna Turkey Bowl
with Bob Saget Marcus Mariota
Bruce development and Mayock we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna talk
some quarterbacks we just saw with
Roseanne dad Arnold and obviously Baker
Mayfield and you know he was on the
Wentz wagon from day one I mean it's
there and yeah ma'am when that trade
went down with the Browns and and the
I'm when the trade went down with the
Rams and the Titans we had him on the
show and he said he thought it would be
for Wentz because he loved him that much
you thought he was so far and clear I
had a golf hmm does he think that still
all the t's a happy Thanksgiving to the
family there and Sammy you where what do
you got going what do you have on tap I
got to I got to work tomorrow night oh
that's right I used to have to do that
act like you didn't know I had to work I
know dan dan up I'll be home with a
drink
there with the family yep rub it in Oh
with the Snuggie all zipped up I love it
and I'll be I'll be watching have a
great past and all right buddy tomorrow
tomorrow night that's Rich Eisen NFL
Network for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]